just being part of a great ensemble
i think that that's my best memory tanya
roberts the actress best known for her
roles
as a bond girl and on that 70s show
died on monday at cedar sinai hospital
in los angeles
she was 65 years old we all have good
stories about bond nothing horrible ever
happens on a bond
no bond is the best the actress
reportedly took her dogs for a walk on
christmas eve
and collapsed after returning home she
was put on a ventilator
but never recovered and according to tmz
the actress did not appear to be ill in
the days leading up to her death
robert's death follows a bizarre turn of
events that started when her boyfriend
lance o'brien first told her rep that
she had died
the publicist initially confirmed
reports of her death on sunday evening
and sent out a press release announcing
the news
but on monday he told people magazine
that the hospital called to share that
roberts was
actually still alive and while it's
unclear
how the misunderstanding happened
o'brien was
mid-interview with inside edition when
he received the call that his girlfriend
was still alive the hospitals told me
she's alive
i'm so happy you don't understand i must
go back
roberts born victoria lee bloom began
her career as a model before breaking
into film with the 1975 horror flick
forced entry after a series of tv pilots
and a number of parts in fantasy films
she appeared in her most iconic role
playing stacy sutton in the 1985 james
bond film
a view to a kill opposite roger moore in
his
last appearance as the infamous british
spy
whether you were buying or selling
silly horses
oh no i'm i'm not interested in horses
roberts was also known for her recurring
role as midge
on that seventy show mitch why do you
have to have your woman warrior meetings
here every week
because none of the other feminist
husbands will let them
she also appeared as julie rogers on the
fifth and
final season of charlie's angels in 1980
look this isn't all as easy and pretty
as it looks
you